pour les abonnés youtube ouais ça avance
tout seul ça s'appelle un escalator mpp
la première anecdote on arrive à
l'aéroport
une heure et demie en avance et malgré
tout ce qui se passe on rate lario
le problème est qu'une enquête publique
c'est dangereux mais on dirait que je
fais une ville de beijing
que de monter ce plaisir ou pour
nouvelle vidéo complètement déjanté sur
renault japonisme je suppose les bleus
qui arrivait de monique vous semblez
c'était les jo
norman est jeune je vous fais parvenir
ce missive message
accepteriez-vous une photo mais ça je
l'écris sur un sac à vomi
on a retrouvé le fameux thomas qui a
laissé un petit mot à dans l'avion à bon
séjour il a dit baisse bien les coquins
s'auto marque on peut clairement dire
purement complaints quelqu'un me de
champlain
toutes ces évolutions
bonjour et quelqu'un rentre dans ma
chambre
c'est faux j'ai complètement entendu des
voix
je suis jeanne d'arc et donne rachid
s'est totalement endormi sur le canapé
en glace c'est un peu dormir vraiment
n'importe quoi
là on est à andorre qui est une petite
vibration peut-être pas sa faute et en
espagne on est sur un petit blog en blog
c'est quoi c'est un vidéo blog un vidéo
lol tu dis plus vite sa faible ouais tu
mélange de mots ça fait un seul mot
parce qu'un mot plus à un mot ça fait un
mois on n'a pas le temps de la neige
attends je me suis en train d'emmener il
ya un gros débat pour savoir qu'est ce
qu'être mieux entre eux snowboard et
patinettes à l'époque noblesse moi je
vais vous dire la vérité je prends de sa
noblesse que c'est un concours plus vite
et je prends plus de plaisir car quand
on regarde le mec a ici c'est quoi
snowblade non c'est le snowboard
oui mais tu ne feras jamais sert-il au
maghreb
ce mec va faire des patinettes savez
vous regardez tout seul on est sur le
télésiège avec qui touchent ils soient
énormes y avait un mec et s'y installer
avec nous il ya cet homme est tombé du
télésiège sans problème et la
quotidienne ce qui tout seul et michel
souvent son bâton doit lever canada dirt
et catalan c'est la paille la fin je
suis qu'à bosser mon gars alors là on
est carrément passé on n'est pas ça très
très gros bouchons les tirs face ça pose
de problème à personne c'est un calme
aux fesses de gand samba le principe de
l'espagnol c'est une langue qui peut
parler que de ces 15 minutes
un vrai plaisir
voilà ma coupe de cheveux après trois
heures de snow complètement défoncée cet
homme et bob marley en réincarner
derrière abus sega espère que vous êtes
bien m'amuser
un vrai plaisir de glisse surtout le
moment j'avais la tête dans le sol dans
la neige c'est vraiment kiffé on se
prend une vraie claque de paysages c'est
bizarre de voir des publicités pour le
tabac les gens te disent vraiment fume
beaucoup sa rentrée très bien en de
respawn pas la tête ils ont carrément le
pack bouteilles de sky double cartouches
pour se déchirer la gueule le pack
pochtron le kit du bon soûlard de
trouver mieux aucun rapport ils font
carrément donc le pack double cartouches
de kamel avec un bras selphy ces deux
objets n'ont aucun rapport n'a aucun
sens ce pack
ils ont mis deux poissons panés je suis
hyper content pour ça tu clairement
hyper contents les gars je suis à votre
message
qu'est ce que je vais faire de
l'hélicoptère moi j'ai un peu peur aussi
je t'avoue que ça commence à chocques
haute voix ça commence clairement à
chocottes en expression d année son 10
ok le
c'est pas juste fait peur
ainsi des gages sur l'électro
terry
j'ai vaincu une phobie la gtoi si vous
savez 28 ans que je flippe de monter
dans un hélico pour ton c'est mon gros
rêve
hu a vaincu la phobie de boukhadra
astuces pour apprendre à bien manger
cabaye est très très simple jeu murbach
tu prends les baguettes tu les mets ici
et du projet - la touche à tout il
explique aux gens sur le jeu ridicule de
gamin tu fais c'est que je mets mes
écouteurs il dit des connaisseurs mois
des vérités ces personnes
moi je n'achète vieux temps
jlt 102,8 ritchie on attend beaucoup
d'elle un modèle chez look à la patate
est maintenant et les mendiants montre
confiant j étais pas de tout repos
j'ai perdu deux vertèbres c'est génial
mais je devrai chez le kiné mais sinon
c'est bien ça le couac en duo prend
l'air aujourd'hui j'ai réalisé l'un de
mes rêves que j'aurais dû faire depuis
que suis vraiment tout petit du chien de
traîneau et je ferais peut pas d'aimer
son super mignon fois c'est le chien de
traîneau qui ont vraiment un style de
dobermann de test le danger est totale
ces chiens sont des punch en attaque
oh non il faut de la peine un peu j'aime
bien lui laisser mon pote comme
s'appellent jacques pas le jeu est
vraiment préfère largement une petite
poignée de main bien viril tu te caresse
entraînements non
donc rassurez vous les chiens sont
totalement en bonne condition et n'ont
pas froid du tout contrairement à ce que
je pensais
tata motors on est parti
et tous trois en anglais
oh
mes doigts sont des mister freeze tient
france à guingamp n'avait pas d'odeur ya
vraiment une bonne odeur de bush y
entrer dans une de niche ou hors
du malecon dinos j'aurais jamais cru est
ici
je dois pendant un moment de aussi
incroyable donc c'est pas pour moi
ok il aime les chiens aucun hellemmes
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ce petit
blog est assez petite vidéo du petit
bonus appelez le comme vous voulez en
tout cas nous on s'est bien fait de le
faire on a kiffé ont présenté les
vacances on sait abonnez-vous à la
chaîne youtube et nationales allaient
rachida beaucoup à très très bientôt
ciao
rigueur cette fois j'ai pas pu me
tromper c'est sûr c'est exactement ce
que tu veux un nouveau mec a nommé alors
là c'est parfait merci